- I'm just not going to
work that hard tonight.
This time, you may have
gotten too close to the edge.
Can we actually spot some
of those innovative ideas?
The only time the the
success comes before work
is in the dictionary.
Working with smart people
means that you'll be
challenged to do your best.
Technology companies
live and die by talent.
We want them to do the
three things twice as well
or do we want to do twice as many things?
Be an information fountain.
Are you on a trajectory for success
or are you on trajectory for failure?
And we basically did each of
those in a really small scale.
- She's an American
businesswoman and the president
and CEO of Yahoo.
Previously she was a longtime executive
and key spokesperson for Google.
Forbes estimates her net
worth to be $380 million.
She's Marisa Mayer and here are
her top 10 rules for success.
(swooping, ball bouncing)
- I've always had a
philosophy around balance.
A lot of people talk about balance,
I don't really believe in balance.
But I do believe in finding your rhythm.
And I think a lot of it has to do not with
three square meals a day,
time at home at night,
eight hours of sleep, I think
it has to do with resentment.
Because I think what fuels
burnout is this notion of
well wait I sacrificed this thing,
and it honestly meant too much to me
and it made me resentful
and for me it's really about
being able to walk out of
the office for one week every
four to six months, find
if I start pushing that out
or delaying vacations
I'll be like you know,
I'm just not going to
work that hard tonight.
I didn't get to take that
trip I really wanted to take.
So I think you can work arbitrarily hard
for really hard periods of time,
but you need to know yourself well enough
that you can avoid
resentment and avoid burnout.
Doing something you aren't
ready to isn't comfortable.
For me, and I assume for
many of you it gives you that
uneasy upset feeling in your stomach,
that sense that this
time you may have gotten
too close to the edge.
But in pushing through that discomfort,
you'll learn a lot more about yourself.
You'll learn to do something
you didn't think you could do.
Or you'll learn where your limits are.
Either is valuable.
It's important to push
through that uneasiness though
because in that moment
of finding your courage
you really grow and you really reach.
I'll say it again, do something
you're not ready to do.
- There's a natural conflict isn't there
in the world of technology
between innovation and execution?
We see many companies struggling with it.
Can both be done well at the same time?
- It's funny because it
was pointed out to me
a few years ago that one
hypothesis is that innovation,
if you think about, what's
the opposite of innovation?
A lot of people would say
well it's the status quo,
it's stagnancy.
And there's another school
of thought which says that
the opposite of innovation is execution.
That if you have to be in
heads down execution mode,
it's very hard to find
the space to innovate,
to have those new ideas
and to pull things in.
And I know that for us at Yahoo right now,
this is going to be a
great period of execution.
Can we take these
products that we have and
revitalize them for the web?
And also make the transition to mobile?
And while we're doing that execution,
will there be room to innovate?
To say hey, this is how Yahoo
Groups worked on the web,
but now there's all these
new opportunities in terms of
how group communication
should work on the phone.
Can we actually spot some
of those innovative ideas?
And I think there is, but it's hard
'cause I do think that
they are natural opposites.
- Is size a barrier to innovation?
- I don't think so because
I think you can innovate
at scale and with large size,
but you have to be very
principled about it.
You know if you have,
say, 10 engineers and
you're going to grow that to be 20 or 30,
do you want to be doing
the same set of things
two or three times better?
Or do you want to be doing two
or three times more things?
And in terms of really, interestingly,
in terms of execution,
this is a great example
of why they're so opposite,
so much opposites that
if you really wanted to execute perfectly,
get the design exactly
right, really work though
all the details, you didn't
ask two to three times
as many people per project.
If you want to find those new ideas,
those far flung ideas,
those things you might not
otherwise find, you want
to take those same people
and put them on something that's far flung
that you've never thought about.
And so it really is that
there is this tension.
So I think that you can innovate at scale,
but you need to save
room to have small teams
working on those far flung ideas.
- What's the most
important thing that you do
to get it all done?
- Hmm.
You have to ruthlessly prioritize.
And I do, and that's one of the reasons
I haven't been talking
and I'm going to go back
to not talking for a while after tonight
because I've been really
internally focused.
You know I'm from Wisconsin and
in Wisconsin you know there's
all kinds of different people
but the one thing that's true of all of us
is we all follow the Green Bay
Packers to different degrees.
And
the Green Bay Packers, the
legacy and the lore there
comes from their first
coach Vince Lombardi
who coached them to their
early Super Bowl wins.
And he's actually quite a pundit.
It turns out these kind
of phrases you hear
like "quitters never win
and winners never quit,"
that's a Lombardi quote.
Right, now "the only time
success comes before work
is in the dictionary," that's
a Lombardi quote, right?
And Vince Lombardi says "in my
life there are three things,
"God, family, and the Green
Bay Packers, in that order."
Right? (laughing)
And I think that for me
it's God, family and Yahoo
in that order.
Find the smartest people you can
and surround yourself with them.
Working with smart people means
that you'll be challenged to do your best.
You'll have to strive
to keep up with them,
and as a result, they will
elevate your thinking.
When there are better players
around you, you get better.
I first noticed this
when I was growing up.
I had a friend, Laura Beckman.
Laura tried out for the volleyball team
her junior year of high school,
and at the end of the tryouts
was given a hard choice.
Bench on varsity or start on JV.
Most people when they're
faced with this choice
choose to play, I will pick JV.
Laura did the opposite, she chose varsity.
And she benched the whole season.
But then an amazing thing happened.
Senior year when she tried
out, she made varsity
as a starter, and all the JV starters
from the previous year benched.
And I remember asking
Laura, how did you know
to choose varsity?
And she said, I just knew.
I just knew if I got to
practice with the better players
every day I would become a better player
even if I didn't get to play in the games.
How does this sporting example
relate to smart people?
I deeply believe that the same
thing happens intellectually.
When you surround
yourself with smart people
they challenge you to think harder
and in entirely different ways.
- What have you focused on?
What are you most excited
about when it comes
to innovative technologies,
particularly the ones
you have some control over?
- Well I was really overall just genuinely
pleased and surprised.
I knew that there had to
be great people at Yahoo.
The same way that when
you sometimes look at art
you can tell if it was created
by a nice person or not or
a depressed person or not.
And when you feel Yahoo's
products you can tell
that there's really nice, very smart
competent people there
that have a great time.
And it's true, it's a
great company overall
that has a very fun culture.
And for my first few months
my focus really was on people.
Because I believe fundamentally that
technology companies
live and die by talent
and that's why when people
talk about the talent wars,
it's not really that some of the companies
that are in the talent
wars are that competitive
with each other, it's just
that when you start to see
the best people migrating
from one company to the next,
it means then that the
next wave is starting.
And so I got very focused on people,
building the right team,
particularly the executive layer
but all through the business.
And also the overall environment.
And part of that was because
I wanted to make sure that
Yahoo was absolutely
the best place to work
and the people really wanted
to come and work there
because that will help
with the talent piece.
But also because I believe
that really strong companies
all have very strong cultures.
And Yahoo's no exception, it's
been a very strong company
for a very long time,
it's got a strong culture.
It's different from every
other corporate culture.
Each has their own unique
and individual flavor.
And I really wanted to
find a way to amplify it.
Because in amplifying it,
that's how you find the energy.
And the energy is what you can
harness into that innovation
and say, OK, if we have people
and they are really excited
about what they're working on every day
and they realize that the
next big hurdle is mobile,
you can take that energy
around the culture
and find fun ways to apply it
that can be really
impactful for end users.
We like to work with really small teams.
When I started there
were about nine engineers
and Larry and Sergey said
well, we have nine engineers
and right now they do about
three different things.
So if we double and we have 18 engineers
would we want them to do the
three things twice as well?
Or do we want to do twice as many things?
And they said well
obviously we'd want to do
twice as many things. (laughing)
And so that's how we've grown.
We've tried to keep the teams really small
which leads to a sense of empowerment,
people making decisions,
around what's the best feature?
What do their users need?
How are they going to
build the best product?
And it allows also for
them to be really agile.
We try and avoid meetings
and like a lot of reasons,
one of the great things that
happens with a small team
is you can put them
all in the same office.
At Google we usually
have three or four people
in each office and that
works really well because
when they wanted to make a decision
people just roll back from
their desk and say hey!
- [Charlie] Turn around
go what about this?
- I've got something that
we need to decide right now.
So that allows the teams
to really be very agile.
Be an information fountain.
Information used to be
scarce and expensive
and power came through
hoarding it and brokering it.
Today it's just the opposite.
Power comes from sharing information.
Tell everyone everything.
The more valuable the better.
Sharing leads to connections,
connections lead to collaboration,
collaboration leads to
creativity and innovation.
Creativity and innovation
are what change the world.
Lack of sharing can kill
innovation in big companies
where divisions turn into
information fortresses.
They compete with each other
and end up guarding information
from each other as zealously
as they do from competitors.
Everyone loses as a result.
Help others find their way
by sharing the information
and ideas you have.
- I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about how failure sits in the middle of
startups and entrepreneur.
- Well failure is a fact of life.
The most important thing of course
is to learn from failure.
But I also think that the other thing
that people don't realize about failure
is that it's totally fine
as long as you do it fast.
(laughing)
Right?
So if you fail fast and then
you're on to the next thing
that's actually successful,
you're much better off.
And so you've got to be
constantly monitoring your effort,
figuring out are you on
a trajectory for success?
Or are you on a trajectory for failure?
And if you're on a trajectory for failure,
decide to fail fast, give it up,
and move on to the next
thing that can be successful.
To me, 2014 was our time
to do a lot of different experiments.
We experimented with some partner content,
we experimented with some
live content with Live Nation.
We had a lot of our editors
in different verticals
work on their own series and clips
of what they wanted to work on.
We did some original content.
And we basically did each of
those at a really small scale
to understand what worked well,
what did we think we
produced with quality?
What did our audience respond to?
And now in 2015 returning
to it we're really looking
and saying OK, what we
saw work really well
was the magazine content,
the deep verticals that
Yahoo's always been known for.
How can we build out more video there?
How can we work out more on content?
So when we do things like The Ultimate DJ,
we're going to be running
an American Idol-like show
with Simon Cowell to find the
bet DJ in the world next year.
That aligns really
deeply with Yahoo music.
The NFL opportunity aligns
really deeply with Yahoo Sports.
And so I think that it really
helped us shape our content
experience to think about, let's
run a bunch of experiments,
build a bunch of different
prototypes, see what works
and what really our users respond to,
and that's things like Live Nation
and some of the verticals
we've always been strong in,
and then how do we build even
more content in that vein.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Home Akaza asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Marissa's top ten rules
meant the most to you and
had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(swooshing, ball bouncing)
- You described, a couple of months ago
how one of your employees asked how Yahoo
is going to compete if it doesn't have one
of these four key
distribution technologies.
There's the mobile operating
system, mobile hardware,
the browser and social.
I don't know that we got an answer.
- Yeah so it was funny
'cause one of our employees
at one of the company meetings asked that
and they said given that we
don't have mobile hardware,
mobile OS, a browser or a social network,
how are we going to compete?
- That's not just a question for Yahoo,
clearly it's a question for every company
that seeks to compete with
those others that have those
key enabling technologies.
- Sure, and you know, of the
four horsemen of the internet
to adopt that analogy, almost
all of them are playing
in one if not several of those medium.
But I think that the big piece here
is that it really allows us to partner.
Yahoo's always been a
very friendly company,
has always been, because
of our focus also,
in addition to technology
but also on media,
it ultimately means that
there's really an opportunity
for strong partnerships
and that's what we'll
be focused on so we work with,
for example, Apple and Google.
In terms of the operating system,
in terms of the social
network we have a strong
partnership with Facebook.
And so we're able to
work with some of these players
that have a lot of strength
in order to really bolster
our user experiences
that we offer on the Yahoo site.
My advice for women is
the same as it is for men
which is that you should find something
that you're really passionate about
because passion is a
gender neutralizing force.
- Lovely!
- And I really
think that you should work for
someone who believes in you.
Work for people who believe
in you and invest in you
because that's how you'll
go far in your career.
You're going to give
them a lot of your time,
be it your own startup, be it
a company that you're joining.
And you want to make sure that you also
get the responsibility and the fulfillment
that you're looking for.
And so those are my two words of advice.
Find somewhere where
you're really passionate,
find somewhere where
someone believes in you,
and I guess my third piece of advice is
find somewhere very comfortable.
It's interesting for me
because I'm a very shy person
by my nature
and at Google people don't
believe I'm shy at all
because I'm very comfortable there.
And that I think is really important,
one of the most important
things for all entrepreneurs,
especially for women
is to find your voice.
And if you can't express
what you're thinking
and what you believe
in, that's a real issue.
And so I think it's really important for
women entrepreneurs
especially to find somewhere
where they're comfortable.
The ads in email story is actually
a really embarrassing story for me.
In terms of how I almost blocked
a multi billion dollar business.
(laughing) So it was
the early days of Gmail.
I was the product manager,
my office mate, Paul Buchheit
was the technical lead.
And you know, you're
musing about a product,
and you're building it,
and you're speccing it.
But every now and then you just kind of
need to take your mind off of it
and brainstorm further in the future.
And so one night Paul
and I were in our office
and we always have
shared offices at Google
so there's three or four
of us in there and Paul
was like, how are we ever
going to make money from email?
And I was like well Paul, this is simple,
everyone's offering four
megabytes in storage,
we're going to offer like
a gigabyte of storage
and we'll give people
some amount of storage
like a gig for free and
then we'll charge them for
more space.
Simple, (mumbling).
And he's like I'm not so sure.
I think we should maybe
target ads at the email.
And I was like you know Paul,
that's going to be just creepy.
So we do say this to each other sometimes.
I was like, people are going to think
that everyone's reading their email
and putting these ads against it.
That's a really bad idea.
And we argued and argued
and argued about it.
I was like Paul, we don't
even have an email program
that can send and receive
email for more than
the six of us that are using
it right now. (laughing)
'Cause we had this little program inside.
And he was like, fine, and
I was like how about we just
figure out like, how to
get this working before we,
you know, really go into a lot of detail
about how we're going
to make money from it?
And
Paul and I were both night owls and so
around three in the
morning I went to leave.
And I remember walking out the door
'cause Paul would come
in, he was sort of like
the typical engineer,
come in about noon and so
I left at three, Paul
was still working away.
And I remember walking out the door,
we had this little glass panel.
As I walked out I leaned back and I said,
so Paul, we agreed, we're
not going to explore
that ads idea, right
now, right? (laughing)
And Paul was like oh,
yeah yeah, yeah yeah.
And so Paul stayed for another four hours
until seven AM when he
went home, building stuff.
And
as I said there were
six of us in the company
using the early form of Gmail.
And I came back in at
like nine in the morning,
logged into my email and
there were ads everywhere!
(laughing)
And so Paul had hooked up this
system that grabbed keywords
out of your email and
put ads against them.
And I was like oh no!
Larry and Sergey are going
to show up at like 11.
They're going to log into their email,
there's going to be ads everywhere.
But I was like you know,
but I could tell from Paul's
emails to me at the end of the night
he had been working till at least seven.
So I was like I don't
want to wake him up now.
But I'm going to have to
call him at like 10:30
and be like, you've got to log
in and like, turn this off.
And so the funny thing was
then I had from like nine
until 10:30 to kind of play with it.
And Al Gore was coming by the office,
and there was an ad for Al Gore books.
And one of my friends
had mailed me and said
do you want to go for a hike this weekend?
And there was an ad for hiking boots.
And I was like you know,
these ads aren't bad.
They're at least relevant if not useful.
And so by 10:30 I decided
I wasn't going to call Paul
and Larry and Sergey came in
and then this interesting thing happened
where, and it's sort of
interesting in terms of history
'cause people get confused.
You're building Gmail, and I do think that
whether or not targeting ads at email
is still an open question, is
still an open issue of debate
between Paul and I maybe
that's how we do it.
But what happened that night
was Paul basically figured out
how to target our text
ads that had been running
alongside of search at content.
Which traditionally on
the web, about 5% of
page views that are done
every day are searches.
So if you walk into a
cybercafe or a classroom
about one in 20 screens
will have a search page up.
Which basically meant we
had a great database of ads
that was good at making
money from 5% of the web.
What Paul had done was
given any paragraph,
given any amount of text,
he could find a relevant ad
from our database to run alongside it.
And so it basically was a way
of taking our ads database
and saying we're not just
going to put these ads
on Google Search, we're going
to put these ads out on the web.
So today when you see
those blocks of textual ads
that say Ads By Google on the bottom,
that's something called AdSense
and it was actually born that night.
And it in truth is actually
much more successful
than even ads inside of Gmail were.
'Cause Larry and Sergey
said wow, this is amazing.
Let's rip this out of Gmail,
just let people run this
on whatever pages they
have on the web which meant
that bloggers could
suddenly quit their job
and blog full time 'cause
they could make money from it.
And people, like About.com
were like we can put
even more content online 'cause
we can make money from it.
And so
you know we launched AdSense
which I think last year
was somewhere in the five
to seven billion dollar
revenue range.
So it was just this
really amazing thing where
that Gmail, that experiment
that happened inside of Gmail
became this big product outside which
I almost quelched with my hey Paul,
we agreed we're not doing
that right now right?
(laughing)
But you know, those types
of things it's just,
it's that Pasteur quote,
"chance favors the prepared mind."
You're messing around
with these types of things
and seeing potentials
and opportunities and
whether or not ads in
email is a good idea,
thinking about how ads
could target at email
let us take ads and target
it really broadly at content.